so I recently got certified as a Google
Cloud professional machine learning
engineer now how did I do that and for
that matter why did I do that well keep
watching cuz I'm going to tell you all
about it I'm Richard and this is Richard
on data so yeah there's this piece of
paper out there that claims I know a
thing or two about machine learning
engineering on gcp that is the Google
Cloud platform I'm going to start with
why I wanted to do this thing in the
first place and what this exam even is
then I'm going to get into exactly what
resources I used how I prepared for this
thing in the days leading up to it and
even some of my impressions of the
actual test once I started taking it so
watch to the very end for that before I
do that take just one moment to smash
the like button and subscribe to this
channel if you haven't already all right
so as you all know I'm a data scientist
so why exactly did I want to become a
certified professional machine learning
engineer well part of it for me had to
do with upskilling a few years ago all I
knew about working in the cloud was
laying in the grass and pointing up at
things and saying huh that kind of looks
like an elephant I'm exaggerating
slightly but not by much frankly Cloud
platforms aren't the only way that you
can deliver production data science
Solutions but they greatly expand your
capabilities to do so now at my company
I had recently started extensive work in
the Google Cloud platform space where
there was an explicit expectation that
my team was going to be able to deliver
Solutions and not only that just for the
sake of my own professional development
I just wanted to be as competent and
confident as possible in the devops and
production side of solution delivery so
I set a goal at the beginning of 2023
which was even with all this crazy
personal stuff I was doing like planning
a wedding and buying a house I would
prepare for this exam take it and pass
it before the end of the year and just
to give some more full context on my
background here I was Far short of the
expertise that Google Cloud recommends
for this Google Cloud recommends about
one year of expertise with their
platform before you take this thing well
I had worked on a migration project from
Microsoft Azure to gcp for about four or
five months before I took this exam and
I really didn't have that much more
expertise Hands-On beyond that now that
was incredibly value able experience
that I definitely needed so it's one
thing to be on the internet somewhere
and read about the difference between
let's say cloud run and Cuba flow
pipelines it's a completely different
experience when you're sitting in a roll
and you need to make some kind of
decision about the best solution for
orchestrating a pipeline that has to
execute once a day so all that is to say
Google Cloud's recommendations are
probably a little bit exaggerated but
you definitely would want to come into
this exam with some experience so now
that we've established why I wanted to
take this thing let's talk about what
the exam even is so the Google Cloud
professional machine learning exam is a
60 question exam that you have 120
Minutes to take and it's all multiple
choice questions now the best summary of
this thing is its official exam guide
but keep in mind I took this exam in
November of 2023 and I'm recording this
video in December of 2023 and the exam
has already changed since then and it's
almost certainly going to change again
soon to reflect generative AI since
that's such a Hot Topic right now so
let's briefly talk about what's on this
exam and arguably even more importantly
what's not on it first of all there's
almost zero coding questions on it I
think when I took it there was one
question with some sequel code in it and
that was pretty much it also since I
took it there seemed seems to be a lot
less questions about classification
metrics so things like Precision recall
P F1 score all that good stuff when I
took it there were a lot of questions
about how to frame a problem like is ml
even a good solution for this problem is
this a good case for a regression or
clustering or classification or
recommendation Engine Solution I'm not
totally sure on this but just from
perusing the exam guide now it looks
like those kinds of questions are
significantly scaled back instead you do
get a ton of questions about automl
pre-trained apis and which one is better
there's a lot of specific questions
about those Solutions and different
types of data data pre-processing some
stuff on pii and
Phi now I don't remember when I took it
anything about Jupiter notebooks but I
guess that's in there now then you get
into section three which is all about
scaling prototypes into ml models now
one point I want to call attention to is
this piece about appropriate Hardware I
remember more than a few questions on
the exam about CPUs versus gpus versus
tpus as well as distribution strategies
then moving on to section four there's a
ton of questions about the distinctions
between anything served online versus
with batch serving there's a big topic
here around scaling served models then
there's a ton of questions around
orchestrating pipelines this is where
knowing the difference between these
different tools is really helpful for
example Cloud build is for continuous
integration and continuous deployment
Cloud run is for running containerized
applications and I remember seeing lots
of questions testing your knowledge of
distinctions like that and then under
this last section six this is another
section I remember seeing a lot around
you've got questions around bias and
fairness you get questions about
training serving skew and feature drift
and a few about what even makes sense as
a baseline for monitoring model
performance so now that we've
established what is and isn't on this
exam how in the world do you actually
prepare for it this is the hard part
because there isn't one single
comprehensive One-Stop shop that you can
go to prepare for this exam and even if
there were it would have to be updated
constantly but I'll detail all the
resources that I personally used in
total I used one book some medium
articles some corsera courses some
practice exams and chat GPT first things
first I bought this book journey to
become a Google Cloud machine learning
engineer the link to that will be in the
description of this video honestly there
were a few chapters of the book that I
just kind of skimmed over but the
content around developing and deploying
ml models and the content around neural
networks and tensor flow and Caris is
excellent same with this whole chapter
on vertex AI from looking at the new
exam guide vertex AI stuff seems more
and more important so that's another
great one to know really well then
perhaps most importantly there's also a
practice exam in the back with 30
questions I found these to be excellent
questions and to match the difficulty
level of the questions on the actual
exam pretty much perfectly then
sometimes it's helpful to hear
perspectives from Real World people
who've taken this exam too so I read
several medium articles from people who
had passed the exam where they laid out
their recommendations their approaches
and their opinions and it's really
helpful just because with an exam with
this much content on it it's useful to
get some kind of feel for what you
should prioritize and what topics seem
to come up the most a lot of these
articles are going to point you to
corsera as the backbone of any sort of
prep that you do now I'll admit I'm not
the world's largest fan of
corsera and the courses for this
particular program vary pretty wildly in
quality I did find some of them pretty
dry but more of them than not were at
least somewhat worth doing I think the
most important ones for me were
Enterprise machine learning production
machine learning systems and pipelines
on the Google Cloud I found these
courses to be both highly in instructive
and highly relevant to the actual
content on the exam so what I would
usually do is put the video lectures on
1.25x to 1.5x speed I would go through
them and take notes on some key Concepts
and I would also go through the labs
pretty quickly granted I could have done
some more and gotten more out of these
Labs but since I already knew there was
pretty much no coding on the exam I was
more focused on just making sure that I
had the key Concepts down and
essentially moving on to the next thing
I'd say the most valuable content from
these courses is the quizzes these
really helped to drive home key Concepts
from the courses and a lot of them were
pretty comparable in quality and
difficulty to exam questions so for me
it was about one week or so before the
exam but at some point it's absolutely
critical to test your knowledge and
start taking practice exams for me I
also started going over a lot of the
quiz questions from from corsera again
too there's a few different practice
exams floating around out there on the
internet but a couple that stand out to
me are the one in the journey to become
a Google Cloud machine learning engineer
book and Google's own sample questions
the interesting thing about Google's own
practice exam is that I actually found
the average difficulty of these
questions to be significantly higher
than the actual exam questions so let's
go over a couple of these questions
here's one example it's about you need
to develop an online model prediction
service that accesses near realtime
features and returns a customer churn
probability value the features are in
big query and updated hourly and now
this is really important it says the
service needs to be low latency and
scalable and require minimal maintenance
so you get all these different
possibilities here you've got you could
use memory store you could use vertex AI
feature store
uh you could use Google kubernetes
engine uh you could use a custom
prediction endpoint in vertex Ai and
once you start looking at the answers
you see the problems and the
distinctions between some of these but
basically the memory store is going to
be lower latency than the vertex AI
feature store and you don't want to use
the Google kubernetes engine because
it's just going to be higher maintenance
so the question's really testing your
knowledge of these sorts of distinctions
now here's another sample question and
this one is all about pii and privacy
issues which is a pretty hot topic on
the exam says you've developed a tree
model based on a feature set of user
behavioral data now there's new
regulations that require anonymizing pii
uh you know that that exists and you
want to update your model pipeline to
adhere to the new regulations while
minimizing a drop in model performance
what should you do and the keys here are
you end up having to train the model
from scratch because if you just tune
the existing model it's not recommended
because the original training might have
memorized sensitive information and you
don't want to use something like masking
because it doesn't enforce referential
integrity and it's probably going to
drop the performance of the model again
just the kind of things that the exam
tests you on that you need to know what
I ended up doing is taking the exams
over and over again to a point where I
basically memorized the question
questions but the point is you have to
be really attentive to the specific
verbage in these questions and you have
to be intimately familiar with the
differences in different
Technologies but over time you're going
to start seeing some patterns show up I
remember a number of questions talking
about accuracy on the training set was
like
99% so it turned into pretty much a dead
giveaway that there's a problem and that
problem is data leakage now this is
where I started using chat GPT a little
bit in the days leading up to the test
to really quickly summarize and iron out
the differences between these
Technologies and Concepts here's an
example where I asked chat GPT what's
the difference between data flow and
data proc and here's a hint you need to
know this on the exam because there's a
lot of questions about it and in the
response there's a few key points here
number one data proc is used for the
deployment of Apache Hadoop or spark
Frameworks it also doesn't handle native
support for stream processing but data
flow excels at that so that's one
example here's another I didn't know as
much about tensorflow distribution
strategies so I asked for a summary of
the difference between mirrored strategy
multi-worker TPU and parameter server
and this was a super amazing summary
which was a great help for me when I was
getting ready I've never personally been
really big on creating flash cards but I
know a lot of people are and this is
kind of a great application for that so
then I finally got to the test day and
that was an experience I took the exam
on my own personal computer in an online
proor environment and the exam ended up
getting delayed by an hour and a half
due to weird technical problems so we
were already off to a great start then
when I finally got to take the actual
test I got to the first two or three
questions and I thought why exactly did
I do this to myself again but by the
time I got through every single question
and then went back over everything and
reviewed I realized I was pretty much
100% sure on roughly half of the
questions and for a lot of the rest of
them I at least had a pretty good guess
there were probably about 10% of the
questions which I had just absolutely no
idea about whatsoever and I just put B
for all of them now the way the exam
results are set up it doesn't break down
what you got right or wrong and it
doesn't even give you a final percentage
score my best guess as to why that is is
because a lot of the questions ask for
the best way to do something so multiple
options are technically correct but some
are better than others so Google might
be allotting partial credit for some of
the answers it's just a theory it's
really impossible to say all of that to
say though it felt really good and
frankly really surprising when I
submitted the test and then not 2
seconds later I got back this screen
that said result pass so to recap that
was my experience with the Google Cloud
professional machine learning exam and
to sort of summarize here the exam is
really hard but all of this is a pretty
doable process if you're a person with
some data and machine learning exposure
and just a little bit of cloud
experience you can get through it my
final comment would be if you put the
time into this thing and be smart about
how you're using your time you take take
advantage of all the different resources
that are out there and you test your
knowledge you too can get a passing
score on this exam so thanks for
watching this video If you enjoyed it
hit the like button if you hated it I
guess you're more than welcome to hit
the dislike button then leave me a
comment down below and let me know your
thoughts do you have any questions about
my experience taking the exam are you
interested in taking it
yourself let me know then I'll see you
all in the Noto distant future until
then
Richard on data